WOMAN: Don't even worry about
getting the education,
just do what you need to do
on the field.
MIKE SHAW:
So many kids get it sugarcoated.
♪ (INTENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
'Cause everybody's
telling them
they're the best player
in the world.
SHAMAR GRAVES: You send
young kids on a roller coaster.
You recruit 'em,
you bring 'em in.
As soon as we sign you switch up
and you're here for a job.
(COACHES AND PLAYERS WAR CHANT)
GRAVES:
But then, you don't pay me.
REPORTER: What's at stake
for a university,
if a player makes money
off their own likeness?
The coaches are making millions
coaching players
whose families live
below the poverty line.
SHAW: I thought I'd be playing
professionally right now.
I never would've expected
to be here.
MAN: They're propelling
a billion-dollar industry,
and gettin' a sweatsuit for it.
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
-(LOCKER CLANGS)
-(BASKETBALL NET SWISHES)